[music]
the basic values of our group are solid
rity justice peace and unive
sal human rights the european selec
note green love the way you are made
n germany martin pity if the borde
is the left-wing fraction in the europ
an parliament the left-wing democ
atic opposition here in the house the o
e for social justice  for
peace policy for a fair
trade policy and for humanitarian
human rights european payment
application from spain germany & greet
the green series is committed to climate justice in the
european parliament
we ensure
tax justice, which means that
corporations and the wealthy have
to pay their fair share of tax revenue again
and we  we stand up for the
interests of the working
population,
that means we want to strengthen workers'
rights and also strengthen social
security systems
[music]